[Music]
hello and a very warm welcome to quad
Riga in just a matter of hours Donald
Trump will be inaugurated as 45th
President of the United States
here in Europe many are worried that the
transatlantic partnership stands before
unprecedented challenges Trump has
called NATO obsolete he's convinced that
the EU will fall apart after brexit he's
demanding punitive duties on imported
German cars and he calls Angela Merkel's
refugee policy catastrophic so is Trump
a potential nightmare for Europe that's
what we want to talk about here on
quadriga today and we've invited three
guests who follow transatlantic
relations closely it's a pleasure to
welcome
Arica Hammond she's a business editor
for the Berlin Daily the taps and she
believes Trump might be an opportunity
for Europe by forcing the EU to unite
and it's great to have Eric Kerschbaum
back on the show he's the Germany
correspondent for the Los Angeles Times
that formerly worked with Reuters
he thinks Trump is a loose cannon but he
will soon learn the limits of his powers
thanks to all the checks and balances in
place with Congress and the Supreme
Court and it's great to welcome Tom
Gerber he's a freelance journalist
focusing on us and security affairs in
his opinion in the eyes of many
Americans Germany and other European
countries behave like scroungers when it
comes to NATO membership it's time for
Chancellor Merkel to confront longtime
pampered Germany with reality so Donald
Trump gave his first big interview to a
major German newspaper this weekend he
also spoke to The Times of London and in
it he pretty much questioned every
orthodoxy on which the transatlantic
relationship is based from free-trade to
the European Union as a store source of
stability and peace from the alliance
with Germany to the future of NATO so
I'd like to first of all start out by
asking all of you to just give me a
sense of your reaction and and starting
with you Eric you say Donald Trump is a
loose cannon so would you see the kind
of statements he made in this interview
or his tweets as a real guideline to
what he's likely to do once he's in
office if you listen to his words and
take him at face value it can be pretty
scary he hasn't been acting very
presidential at all and there was a hole
people would become more presidential
and more graceful and reach out to the
to the other side but he hasn't maybe
that'll change when he takes office but
if you look at the interview and build
one thing I thought was optimistic is
that he said NATO is very very important
everybody jumped on the first half of
the sentence when he said NATO is
obsolete but he's been saying that for a
long time but he also said NATO is very
very important for me that was new and
that was a signal you know read
everything he says don't just take he
says a lot of things and if you if you
grab those things he says and you're too
pessimistic about it if you see the
glass as half-empty you're going to be
disappointed I see the glass is
half-full he's got a hundred days to
maybe change and maybe act a little more
presidential and let's see what happens
okay hey man what was your reaction what
what's your reaction altogether as we
approach this really historic
inauguration well what I really found
shocking about this interview was that
it's had so many factual mistakes it
made it was very obvious that Trump
really doesn't know what he talks about
and that I think is a problem for a
president especially that's not new yeah
that's true but you know the other
presidents
always gave this impression that they
want to learn but you know Trump is just
the opposite he claims to know
everything he claims to know how to
change the world he claims to be the
most wonderful businessman there other
wars but at the same time he doesn't
know anything but he doesn't give the
impression that he wants to learn and
that is really dangerous so I'm good as
I mentioned many Europeans who read this
interview were alarmed were you alarmed
not necessarily because he just repeated
what he actually had said prior in in
this election campaign that NATO is
obsolete is not the first time that he
said that what I found interesting is
that it was the first significant
interviewee he has given and that was
for European to European newspapers so
actually I read out of that that he
cares for Europe
Europe is important to him because
otherwise he would not have to give this
interview and say look Europeans I have
to tell you something and what he had to
tell us he did many people in Europe
felt that actually his attitude toward
Europe sounded pretty indifferent you
might refer to his remarks on both
Germany and the EU as damning with faint
praise let's listen to what he had to
say on that point if you look at the UK
if you look at the European Union its
Germany it's basically a vehicle for
Germany that's why I thought the UK was
so smart in getting out I believe others
will leave so in Turkish but would you
expect him on the basis of what he said
there and what he said elsewhere about
the EU to take a sort of a
divide-and-conquer approach and if so
will the US will that really make the
u.s. great again he's always a
businessman he's always thinking of ways
to divide and conquer to get a good
position but what he said there's some
truth to that there's a kernel of truth
to what he's saying that the EU Germany
does profit enormous Lee from the EU
Germany benefits from the EU the euro is
is something that really helps Germany
and its exports I mean Germany is one of
the world's leading export countries so
he's saying something is provocative and
it's not something usually hear from a
president but there's there's some truth
to what he's saying
Arica Hammond you say this could prompt
European countries to pull together
really yes well you know I think that's
a again an instance where Trump just
misrepresented reality because in fact
the Great Britain profited from the EU
even more than the Germans but it's true
that the British didn't realize that but
the so the result of the brexit will be
that they really lose out economically
which will result in all other countries
not to leave the EU I mean the whole
again you know this whole quote shows
that Trump really doesn't know anything
about Europe and do you think the US
would be better off with a divided
Europe economically speaking no of
course not because the United States
profit a lot from their trade with
Europe but one thing is true
us but somehow disturbing for the
Europeans well if there is a country
that doesn't really take part in
globalization its you the US because
it's such a big country that a foreign
trade doesn't really matter a lot I mean
that's another misrepresentation of
Trump he always tries to tell the
Americans that everything would be
better if there wasn't any trade but the
fact is that threat is hardly important
for the u.s. anyway it's just about 11%
of the GDP but I think in the long run
that Trump will not change anything in
these trade relations which cause very
many companies in the u.s. of course
rely on export into the you to Europe I
want to come back to trade a bit later
in the show but Tom Gurley tell me this
doesn't the kind of talk that we heard
there that we saw in that quote EU
bashing and frankly also some Germany
bashing in that interview doesn't that
simply feed resentments of right-wing
political groups here all across Europe
they are very much EU skeptical if not
absolutely opposed to the EU we've got a
really important election year here in
Europe and a number of different
European countries don't you think this
feeds into nationalist right-wing
populism it feeds a couple of things
certainly yes the right-wingers here for
example the AFD in in Germany or in
Netherlands and the pan movement in
France yes they feel backed by by that
kind of remarks from from Donald Trump
without saying that he is the same
caliber as they here I mean we can't
compare both movements so to speak but
it also feeds anti-americanism which is
actually more from the left in Europe in
the sense that the Americans kind of
yeah show now their real face that
Donald Trump is just a voice he voices a
vast majority in the United States which
exists for a long time which is not new
that they Envy the the success of the
European Union the envy the success of
the euro they are not happy actually
with the euro
because Americans in general want their
America first is the dollar first right
and not another similar no not a similar
money and like the dollar so he feeds a
couple of of attitudes or ideas or
opinions and I think he is not always
aware of that or we can Tom gala just
implied that Donald Trump at any rate is
more moderate than European right-wing
populist can we be so sure of that I
wouldn't be too sure because in our in
fact what Trump does is to feed racism
in in the United States the racism will
increase and that's what all black
people or Hispanics report that they
feel insecure in the United States
racism increased under Obama so why do
you expect increase increases even more
because I would not accept your
statement that racism increased no it's
not like it but it's a fact but anyway
now you have a president who endorses
racism that is a fundamental change okay
I want to cut that conversation right
there I'm sorry but I want to try to
move us on to two particular errors
areas that people are quite concerned
about here in Europe not only on the
basis of the interview published this
week but also on the basis of other
statements that Donald Trump has made
namely security on the one hand trade on
the other so let's start out with the
question of security which boils down to
one issue above all could a trump
presidency undermine the very
foundations of the post-war order namely
the transatlantic alliance NATO on the
one hand and the principle of
territorial sovereignty on the other
namely also due to the Russian
incursions into Ukraine so let us talk a
little bit about that and start out by
seeing this report about the people that
Trump has nominated to some of the key
positions involving security
Trump admires Russian President Vladimir
Putin
and sees him as a possible trading
partner but there have been harsh words
for Moscow from Trump's team especially
following allegations of Russian hacking
during the u.s. election this was an
aggressive action taken by the senior
leadership inside of Russia Russia today
poses a danger Trump has characterized
NATO as obsolete
he says the Alliance has problems and
that it has not done enough to fight
terrorism his designated Secretary of
Defense has said NATO from my
perspective having served once as a NATO
supreme Allied commander is the most
successful military alliance probably in
modern world history maybe ever so whose
perspective will win out trumps or that
of his political appointees Eric what do
you say to that question who's likely to
win out if it comes to relations with
Russia we have on the one hand somewhat
moderate statements on what Russia
sceptical statements by the future
Secretary of Defense if in fact he is
confirmed and also on the part of the
future Secretary of State on the other
hand we have some very warm statements
from Trump in regard to Russia it is
confusing I mean it's typical Trump the
last three months and in transition has
been also filled with these
contradictory statements but encouraging
is the Senate hearings that have shown
that that the nominees have different
opinions in Trump and I was encouraged
by that and I think it's a it's a good
sign and Trump has said he's open for
discussions it'll be a new a new way of
maybe public discussions about these
things for most Americans though it is
alarming to see the way putting a Trump
has been so positive about Putin and I'm
sure for a lot of Republicans in
Congress has been very alarming to hear
Trump talking so favorably about Russia
and that's something that's gonna lead
to tension I think in the Congress as
you know congressman the United States
are much more independent than they are
in Germany and I think Trump is gonna be
running into all kinds of problems with
Republican Congressmen unhappy about
this this the the friendship that he's
developing towards Putin indeed the
Congress has decided to hold hearings on
the Russian hacking issue
that perhaps could also turn up things
that might be uncomfortable for Donald
Trump
Arica Hammond people in Washington who
are observers of the political process
say they expect Donald Trump to lead
essentially like a CEO of a group of a
big corporation who sets kind of the
broad lines of strategy but leaves the
details to his ministers on the other
hand his designated cabinet appointees
are also competing centers of power we
have some who are quite pro-russian
others who aren't how do you expect that
to play out I think the most important
problem will be that no one on this
cabinet has any experience with
governing they are all billionaires
coming from outside and I really I think
it will be very curious to see how they
all try to govern a superpower without
having any political experience and all
of them think that they are stars they
all think that they are billionaires
because of their own intelligence not
because they just happened to be lucky
so this is going to be a very
interesting family grouping in a way you
know you can really see them fighting
like children over power influence and
fame in a way so Tom Griffith at the
very least aren't divisions amongst the
various cabinet appointees and perhaps
with Trump as well likely to encourage
divisions in Europe we know that we have
some Eastern European countries terribly
worried about potentially being the next
victims of Russian expansion and on the
other hand we have other Eastern
European countries they would very much
like to do a deal with Russia so what
would you expect all of this to set in
motion here in Europe actually I think
the Germans in particular should be
grateful that Donald Trump is going to
end this terrible tension that the Obama
administration has built up with Putin I
mean that Obama had the guts even to
sent in 4,000 American troops in his
very last days to Poland shows that he
never was able to cope with Putin so we
should be grateful that there is
who at least says I want a new approach
this is a sign of hope and especially
for the for the German left and liberal
sides who always favored we should we
should play down the tension with
poutine I think here is someone who
really can steer the course around to to
the better would that be playing down
the tension or would that be appeasement
it sounds like a piece meant to me I
mean the the NATO countries in Eastern
Europe want the support they've been
begging for support from the United
States and other NATO partners and it's
a small token show of solidarity to send
4,000 troops do you think we'll see them
pulled out again by truck could be I
mean is that in power yet we'll have to
see what happens as defense ministers
not in office yet it's still early days
we'll see let us briefly hear from the
Chancellor because she appears to have
gotten the Trump message that NATO and
Europe need to do a great deal more if
they want to keep the transatlantic
alliance healthy let's hear what she had
to say this week let's not fool
ourselves from the point of view of our
traditional partner I'm thinking here of
transatlantic relations
there is no lifetime guarantee for close
cooperation with us Europeans we must
continually work for it as Europeans
that's why I'm convinced that Europe and
the European Union will have to learn to
take on more responsibilities in the
world in the future
Ulrika Hammond your opening statement
professed the hope that we might
actually see Europeans pull together a
great deal more take a lot more
initiative do you see real signs of that
those are some fine words from the
Chancellor do you think we'll see
actions follow well I think of course
right now everyone just waits what will
happen because so far Trump has not been
president and so far he's been saying a
lot of contradictory
things so no one really knows what he's
up to but I think that even now the
Europeans start to prepare themselves
for being more United because one thing
is very obvious just as mr. Kirschbaum
said it's this try attracted by to Putin
to conquer and divide or divide and
conquer that the Europeans of course
must oppose and they but they didn't
have to do that in in the past but now
they will have to discuss a lot among
themselves before addressing the u.s.
after now they just addressed the u.s.
everyone had his own foreign minister
traveling to Washington and to just talk
to the administration because there was
no harm done that of course will be gone
now before anyone travels to Washington
he will be briefed by all the other
European countries what he is supposed
to say so this style of politics will
change and perhaps even the substance
now Donald Trump's approach not only on
NATO is clearly a transactional approach
as you said he likes to do deals and he
expects that NATO is essentially a deal
and the others need to Adi up if they
want to get American protection the same
approach appears to be guiding him in
the area of trade and I'd like to move
on to that now just briefly because we
don't have a lot of time left he said in
that interview on Monday that you'll
find a Mercedes in front of practically
every luxury home in the US but you
don't find a Chevrolet in front of such
homes in Germany and he threatened
punitive duties of 35% on imported cars
in Europe so Arica Hammond I happen to
be in a German region with a lot of auto
suppliers on Monday as that interview
came out they were deeply alarmed about
this do we have a trade war coming up
well this interview again shows that a
Trump doesn't know what he talks about
because the Chevrolet isn't in Europe
and especially not in Germany because GM
owns open now of course what GM doesn't
want is their Chevrolet's in Germany
compete with open from the same company
so Chevrolet's are not being sold of how
do you say that well you
try to just minimize the Chevrolets
driving around Germany so again Trump is
talking about something that's
completely untrue now if he wanted to
have a tariffs of 35 percent he would of
course hurt American companies as well
because it's you can't imagine him
having 35 percent of a tariff and Europe
not reacting so in the end you would
have a trade war and no one would be
gaining in fact some success with this
rhetoric so far though with with the
carrier air conditioners in Indiana and
with the Ford plants in Mexico and he's
trying to use it against Europe as well
but he's really gonna be shooting
himself in the foot because once again
this shows his powers are limited he
doesn't have the power to introduce 35%
tariff you can only do it for short term
that Congress will have to go along with
this and it's hard to imagine a
Republican Congress that's gonna go
along with a protectionist president the
United States lives from open borders
and free trade there would be some
adjustments to the north american free
trade north american free trade pact but
it's not going to be the end of open
trade for the united states with a
Republican Congress jungle are you quite
sure of that the very people who
supported Trump of course are those most
hurt by globalization many of them the
same groups that support right-wing
parties in Europe many people are saying
the area era of globalization as we knew
it is dead yes I agree the the the area
is is dead but let me come back to this
to this remark of Donald Trump I agree
he can't do what he wants to do it's
impossible he's not mister Almighty but
he obviously delivers to those who
elected him we were voted for him the
workers the the ordinary people who want
to hear and off globalization jobs that
are created for us that is his threats
which by the way worked already in a
couple of examples were for example Ford
States in the US and does not expand to
to Mexico and so forth I think it's more
a message to the domestic it's more a
domestic message than than a world
message and if Germans feel afraid I'm
really it's
a bit laughable because the Germans are
the expert champions in the world and if
they are not able to to bypass things
like that 35% judy's that's a pretty
snake dude
well as I said Donald Trump can't make
what he wants that won't happen
the way he wants it's more a message for
for his for at home than abroad however
the Germans will be able to to to fix
that absolutely can both gentlemen have
said that Trump's words for example to
the automaker Ford in the US or to the
air-conditioner manufacturer carrier
actually produced action in the sense
that jobs stayed in the u.s. critics in
the u.s. say nonsense Ford didn't go to
Mexico because the gas price is too low
it wasn't worth building those cars has
what he has done so far really made any
difference in terms of jobs whatever
influence Trump had one thing you really
have to see is 5,000 jobs in the United
States is just nothing but people keep
forgetting is it's an economy with 320
million people and every day 40,000
people lose their jobs change their jobs
and so on so 5,000 jobs is just nothing
yes it's the problem is in the United
States that the media do not just really
do not report that instead everything
everyone does a huge cover story about
thought building a factory in the United
States or not moving as factory because
of 5,000 jobs and I think that is really
just plain crazy
well it's not quite true Sushma Reuters
certainly did report the skepticism on
the Ford the Ford pressure essentially
pressured that was accomplished with
telephone calls and tweets Trump using
that bully pulpit but would you truly
say the media do not report the other
side of trumps I think I think it's out
there but it's not it's a question of
will people be able to find it in the
flood of information swirling around I
mean I've read it as well so I know it
I've read it in the media is for 5,000
jobs thanks to trump yeah I mean it's
the simplified version Trump has been an
expert
simplified version but the whole message
to BMW exports cars from the United
States around the world so Trump doesn't
really even know what's going on the
United States BMW is a big manufacturer
in the United States back to Europe
because we have just a few a one moment
left in the show and I'd like to get all
of you to answer our title question
briefly if you would please the media
take in Europe is Trump could be a
nightmare
for Germany and Europe what do you all
say yes or no nightmare yes he can be
nightmare because it doesn't know
anything about facts he won't be a
nightmare he will help Europe to
eventually find itself and create a
greater Europe it could be a nightmare
but give them a hundred days and wait to
see it becomes more of a president and
less of the candidate thank you very
much to all of you for being with us
today and thanks to all of you out there
for tuning in see you soon
[Music]